I'm navarre ball and this is bolder
support starting five with any players
in NBA history your dream team alright
my starting five NBA players of all time
would be Magic Johnson at the one
Michael Jordan at the to Mary burned at
the three Tim Duncan at the four and
Shaquille O'Neal at the five parquet
buckets what's the least cool NBA jersey
you can see someone wearing Cavs Anthony
Bennett Lakers Dwight Howard 76ers
Andrew Bynum others out at all three I'd
have to say the Cavs
Anthony Bennett cuz where has he been
Nielsen and basketball the fans chant
defense but never offense why is that
scoring is important too because offense
is spontaneous so you don't have time to
say offense offense
he already slam dunked or didn't move
till defense you play defense for a long
time just keep slide your feet and
deflecting passes but offense it's a
quick move what if you get a steal on
shoot from half-court what time you get
a steal say off now shot it so you can't
say offense offense offense that's why
it's defense Jason Curry
Habs havs does that stand for something
- how did you shoot a free throw someone
tell me so I can tell the Raptors this
is ridiculous I guess you would never
know if you don't get fouled so don't
worry about the free throw game just
worry about getting in the game
six are high compared to your pickup
game style to a current NBA player my
pickup game would be like Charles
Barkley because I don't play in pickup
games anymore and he's not a player
anymore so we own the same boat welcome
to Krispy Kreme Doughnuts ray Bolton
punting do the Warriors have the worst
collective facial hair in the NBA
not going to answer that question
because I don't look at guys faced with
a sprawl Kass
worse NBA draft suit photos only the
worst one has to be I don't know what
this guy's wearing but he's got a
turquoise suit on anybody wearing a
turquoise suit is two steps below the
Joker 12-cup I know this is 12 up what's
the best NBA team of the modern era stop
it I even got a look LA Lakers why
because they have the best ball player
Cletus Murray who do you think has the
worst attitude in the NBA past or
present that's a tricky one because I
think everybody in the NBA has an
attitude it's just when you catch him at
the right time if you think a kid guy
has a bad attitude and he went in all
time he gonna be good but Sussie lose a
couple of games and you'd be like well
what do you think was the problem for
the losing can he go be like you know
it's gonna be like that he's gotta catch
him at the right time
Dennis Smith junior what is the best NBA
arena again Staples Center Christie
flock who has the worst hair in the NBA
the question should a man who has the
best head because everybody got that
crazy hairdo now I don't know what it's
looking like look like they just woke up
and they think that's fresh my son has
that too
but maybe it's the culture these days
it's like you know if it's nap eat you
happy
t-ball I think I would be a great TV
personality how do I get started in the
field of work well I think you need to
go out to your local neighborhood and
start interviewing everybody on the
street
that's a good way to get started so how
do I get to be on the talk show well all
I do is talk about my life by catherine
hall first of all your life better be
interested so I suggest if you have a
boyfriend he actually no questions guess
what don't nobody care about your life
on a scale from one to absolutely effin
baller how baller do I look the dude
called big sexy you know what when you
in an all-white suit with a camouflage
shirt I don't care what nobody say you a
bolder just to come out with that all
here you can't tell him nothing you walk
down the street
you're not a big baller he got to be a
big baller because he didn't want to put
on it I answer any for me but if you
like it like that you a big baller shoe
Gilbert ride seriously wondering how
hard it would be to drop out and be a
baller the dropping out part is very
easy but being a Boulder's will be the
hard part
so I'll let you figure that one out k
Ric are predatory
I got some wicked discount coupons and
in need of some new fresh cakes can you
please help me decide which one do you
like better pics below he has two of
them one looks like a jogger and the
other one looks like a casual shoe the
difference between a jogger and a casual
shoe take the casual because I think you
do less running - ha what a name how do
I even win an argument the best way to
win an argument turn around and go the
other way
we've arguably you want GG God I'm too
broke to be a big bald man how about you
hook me up with some heat so check it
out
let's stop whining about being a big
baller and worried about heat and let's
just be cool and this is baller support
and I've supported the baller all I can
for all this time and internal s
questions we up